>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
HAPPY WEDNESDAY.
WE WANT TO TAKE YOU BACK A
COUPLE OF FEBRUARIES A GO, NOT
TOO LONG AGO BUT A DIFFERENT
TIME.
FEBRUARY 2019, AN AMERICAN C17
CARGO JET TAKES OFF FROM
AIR FORCE BASE FLORIDA BOUND FOR
SOUTH AMERICA.
THE MEDIA ARE COVERING THIS AND
IT IS A BIG STORY.
INSIDE THE PLANE, PALLETS OF
WHEELCHAIRS AND CRUTCHES --
THESE ARE GIFTS THE PEOPLE OF
THE UNITED STATES TO THE LONG
OPPRESSED POPULATION OF
VENEZUELA.
VENEZUELA'S SOCIALIST ECONOMY
FAMOUSLY HAD COLLAPSED UTTERLY
BY THAT POINT.
THERE WAS NO TOILET PAPER IN
CARACAS.
PEOPLE WERE EATING ZOO ANIMALS
TO STAY ALIVE.
THE AVERAGE VENEZUELAN HAD LOST
OVER 10 POUNDS FROM STARVATION.
SO THE POINT OF SENDING
HUMANITARIAN AID TO VENEZUELA
WAS TO SHOW THE WORLD THAT
AMERICANS ARE DECENT, BUT MORE
THAN THAT, THAT THE AMERICAN
SYSTEM WORKS.
THIS COUNTRY IS SO RICH THAT WE
CAN AFFORD TO SEND CRUTCHES AND
WHEELCHAIRS TO OUR ENEMIES.
AGAIN, THAT WAS 2019.
IT WAS NOT THE BERLIN AIRLIFT,
IT WAS THE OTHER DAY.
BUT A LOT HAS CHANGED.
WE ARE NOT SHIPPING ANY MORE
CRUTCHES OR WHEELCHAIRS TO
VENEZUELA OR ANYWHERE ELSE, FOR
THAT MATTER, AND WE ARE NOT
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH FOR
OURSELVES.
LESS THAN A YEAR INTO THE
JOE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, THE
UNITED STATES FACES MASSIVE AND
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS SHORTAGES
OF JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING.
JUST THIS WEEK, ONE OF THE
LARGEST HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS IN
THE UNITED STATES, INTERMOUNTAIN
HEALTH CARE, BEGAN SOLICITING
HELP FROM ITS OWN PATIENTS.
ACCORDING TO A LOCAL NEWS
REPORT, OFFICIALS AT
INTERMOUNTAIN HEALTH CARE WERE
URGING PEOPLE TO "CHECK THEIR
CLOSETS, ADDICTS, AND GARAGES
FOR USED METAL CRUTCHES AND
OTHER ASSISTANCE."
RUNS THE STATE OF UTAH.
I'VE NEVER SEEN THIS, HE SAID.
I PRACTICED HEALTH CARE ON
VARIOUS CONTINENTS AND RECENTLY
MOVED TO THE MIDDLE EAST.
EVERY TIME I COME BACK TO
PRACTICE HEALTH CARE IN
NORTH AMERICA I AM SO GRATEFUL
FOR OUR SUPPLY CHAIN WE TAKE FOR
GRANTED.
AND NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN, WE CAN
SEE THAT WE CAN'T ORDER ANYMORE?
CAN'T ORDER ANYMORE.
NOT A SMALL THING WHEN YOU RUN A
HOSPITAL.
MULTIPLY THAT STORY TIMES AN
ENTIRE CONTINENT AND YOU BEGIN
TO UNDERSTAND THE CURRENT STATE
OF THE AMERICAN ECONOMY.
HOSPITALS BEGGING FOR MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT.
ESSENTIAL GOODS UNAVAILABLE
EVERYWHERE.
SUPPLY CHAINS FROZEN JUST MONTHS
BEFORE CHRISTMAS.
IT'S NOT IMPROVING.
IT COULD GET MUCH WORSE.
VERY QUICKLY.
HERE IS A SNAPSHOT OF WHERE WE
ARE TONIGHT.
>> THE SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUE COULD
BE HITTING YOUR THANKSGIVING
TABLE THIS YEAR.
GROCERY STORES ARE WARNING THEY
ARE EXPECTING A SHORTAGE OF
TURKEYS.
>> STORES ARE STARTING TO SEE
SHORTAGES OF ITEMS SUCH AS PET
FOOD, FROZEN FOOD, AND DIAPERS.
>> SPENT NEARLY TWO DECADES IN
LOUDOUN COUNTY AS A WINEMAKER,
BUT A LACK OF BOTTLES NATIONWIDE
COULD PUT HIS SUPPLY AT RISK.
>> A SHORTAGE OF KETCHUP IS
IMPACTING RESTAURANTS AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
QUANTITIES OF SINGLE-SERVE
PACKETS HAVE DWINDLED DURING THE
PANDEMIC, LEADING THE
TOMATO-BASED PASTE IN SHORT
SUPPLY.
>> THERE ARE CERTAINLY SHORTAGES
OF EVERYTHING FROM BREAD TO
POTATO CHIPS.
EVEN TOILET PAPER.
>> SUDDENLY YOU JUST CAN'T FIND
THE STUFF YOU WANT.
>> BOOK PUBLISHERS ARE HAVING
TROUBLE GETTING PAPER.
CAR COMPANIES CAN'T BUY COMMUTER
CHIPS, BUILDERS HAVING TROUBLE ,
CONTAINER SHIPS IN PORT ARE
WAITING DAYS TO BE UNLOADED.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
IT IS EVERYTHING.
DIAPERS, PET FOOD, KETCHUP,
BREAD, ET CETERA, ET CETERA,
ET CETERA.
THE FORTS, PARTICULARLY THE PORT
OF LONG BEACH, ON THE
WEST COAST, HAVE GOTTEN A LOT OF
ATTENTION.
THE PROBLEM IS BIGGER, NOT JUST
CROWDED PORTS.
THE PROBLEMS BEGIN THOUSAND
MILES AWAY.
OVER THE LAST YEAR, THE AVERAGE
TIME IT TAKES FOR A CONTAINER TO
REACH THE UNITED STATES FROM
ACROSS THE PACIFIC FROM ASIA HAS
JUMPED BY NEARLY 50%.
IT WAS 51 DAYS.
NOW IT IS 74 DAYS.
NOT GOING TO CHANGE ANYTIME
SOON.
THAT MEANS MOST OF WHAT YOU BUY
IN THE STORE OR ORDER ONLINE IS
ABOUT TO BECOME MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE.
AS FOX NEWS WILLIAM LA JEUNESSE
REPORTED RECENTLY, SO MUCH OF
OUR RETAIL ECONOMY NOW DEPENDS
ON THE COST OF SHIPPING GOODS
FROM CHINA.
>> A RECORD 159 SHIPS, 63 IN
PORT, BUT 96 OFFSHORE, WAITING
SOMETIMES WEEKS TO DOCK.
LONGSHOREMEN SAY THEY ARE READY
TO HEED THE PRESIDENT'S CALL FOR
24/7, BUT WHEN THE PORTS ASKED
TRUCKERS TO WORK, THE 3:00 A.M.
TO 7:00 A.M. SHIFT, NOT ENOUGH
SHOWED.
>> WE HAVE THREE SHIFTS, FIRST,
SECOND, THIRD.
THEY CHOOSE NOT TO WORK THE
THIRD BECAUSE NO ONE COMES TO
PICK UP THE CARGO ON THE THIRD
SHIFT BECAUSE ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN, THERE IS NO
PLACE TO TAKE THE CONTAINER.
>> COST OF A SHIPPING CONTAINER
FROM CHINA TO L.A. IS $16,000
COME UP 330% FROM A YEAR AGO, AD
ONCE HERE, THE TRUCKING RATE PER
MILE IS UP 23%, NOT INCLUDING
FUEL.
>> Tucker: SO, TRUCKING COSTS
JUST ONE LINK IN A VERY LONG AND
QUITE COMPLEX CHAIN, TRUCKING
COSTS UP NEARLY 25%, NOT
INCLUDING FUEL.
BUT OF COURSE IN REAL LIFE WE DO
INCLUDE FUEL.
FUEL IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
EXPENSES FOR AMERICANS WHO DON'T
LIVE IN THE URBAN CORE.
THAT IS MOST PEOPLE.
ACCORDING TO AAA, THE AVERAGE
PRICE OF GASOLINE PER GALLON IS
NOW $3.30.
TO REFRESH YOUR MEMORY, JUST A
YEAR AGO, IT WAS ABOUT $2.
THIS COUNTRY HAS IMMENSE ENERGY
RESERVES, UP UNTIL RECENTLY,
BRAGGED ABOUT BEING "ENERGY INDT
WAS GOING TO FREE US FROM OUR
DEPENDENCE ON THE MIDDLE EAST
AND ALMOST POINTLESS WARS THAT
KILLED AMERICANS UNDERRATE OUR
TREASURY.
WE WERE PROUD OF THAT.
HOW DID WE GET ENERGY SHORTAGES
IN A COUNTRY THAT HAS MORE
ENERGY THAN IT CAN CONSUME?
THAT WAS NOT ACCIDENTAL.
IT WAS ENTIRELY INTENTIONAL.
IT WAS THE RESULT OF POLICIES
THAT CAME FROM WASHINGTON.
AND MAYBE THAT IS WHY JOE BIDEN
DOES NOT SEEM UPSET ABOUT IT
WHEN ASKED.
NOW, CARS MAY BE A THREAT TO THE
GLOBAL CLIMATE, BUT MORE
PRESSING, CARS EQUAL PHYSICAL
ECONOMY.
THEY ARE YOURS.
YOU CAN TAKE THEM WHERE YOU WANT
TO.
AND BY THIS POINT WE KNOW VERY
WELL WHERE THIS ADMINISTRATION
STANDS ON THE QUESTION OF
PHYSICAL AUTONOMY, SO WATCH
JOE BIDEN AS HE IS ASKED ABOUT
THIS.
>> DO YOU HAVE A TIMELINE FOR
GAS PRICES AND WHEN YOU THINK
THEY MAY START COMING DOWN?
>> MY GUESS IS YOU WILL START TO
SEE GAS PRICES COME DOWN AS WE
GET BY AND GOING INTO THE
WINTER -- EXCUSE ME, INTO NEXT
YEAR, 2022.
I DON'T SEE ANYTHING THAT IS
GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE MEANTIME
THAT IS GOING TO SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE GAS PRICES.
I DON'T HAVE A NEAR-TERM ANSWER.
>> Tucker: GAS PRICES.
THAT IS NOT SOME KIND OF A
SATIRIC QUESTION.
AGAIN, FOR MOST PEOPLE WHO DON'T
WORK AT NONPROFITS IN WASHINGTON
OR HAVE SIGNED AT McKINSEY,
GAS PRICE IS ESSENTIAL AND
DETERMINES HOW MUCH MONEY HAVE
DAY TODAY YET BIDEN'S RESPONSE,
THE MOST BLASE IMAGINAL.
"I DON'T HAVE A NEAR-TERM
ANSWER."
THAT IS NOT ALWAYS HIS ANSWER,
IT DEPENDS ON WHAT THE QUESTION
IS.
SO, FOR EXAMPLE, THE
ADMINISTRATION THOUGHT IT HAD TO
IMPORT UNVENTED, UNVACCINATED
REFUGEES, BIDEN HAD AN ANSWER,
DESCRIBED IT AS A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY THAT COULD NOT WAIT
ONE MOMENT.
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE MOBILIZED
THE ENTIRE U.S. GOVERNMENT TO
GET THOSE PEOPLE INTO YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
THAT WAS VERY IMPORTANT FOR
THEM.
BUT YOUR HOUSEHOLD BUDGET?
HOW MUCH MONEY YOU HAVE?
WHETHER YOU CAN TAKE YOUR KIDS
OUT FOR DINNER?
WHO CARES?
DEAL WITH IT, LEGACY AMERICAN.
YOU HAVE NO RIGHT TO EXPECT
MORE.
THAT IS THEIR POSITION.
SO SAY GOODBYE TO CHEAP
GASOLINE, PROBABLY FOREVER.
THAT WAS THE BASIS UPON WHICH
OUR MODERN SOCIETY WAS
STRUCTURED.
THAT IS WHY WE HAVE SUBURBS.
BY THE WAY, DEMONSTRATION HATES
BUT MOST PEOPLE ENJOY LIVING
THERE.
YOU CAN'T LIVE IN SUBURBS WITH
GASOLINE YOU CAN'T AVOID.
AND IT IS NOT JUST GASOLINE.
HEATING OIL TOO.
JET FUEL, NATURAL GAS, AND ALL
THE OTHER IMMORAL HYDROCARBONS.
CHEAP FUEL IS OVER IN THIS
COUNTRY, AND IT IS INTENTIONAL.
PERMANENT SHORTAGES AHEAD.
BY THE WAY, IT IS NOT JUST FUEL.
GO AHEAD AND TRY TO BUILD
SOMETHING RIGHT NOW, WE DARE
YOU.
THE FOLLOWING CONSTRUCTION
MATERIALS HAVE NOW BEEN LISTED
AS "DELAYED," MEANING THEY ARE
TOUGH TO GET.
THEY INCLUDE ADHESIVES,
APPLIANCES, COPPER, DRYWALL,
ELECTRICAL EQUIPMENT, FABRICATED
METALS, FURNITURE, HVAC
EQUIPMENT, PVC PIPE, LUMBER,
STEEL, AND SO ON,
ESSENTIALLY A MUCH EVERYTHING.
GOOD LUCK FIXING YOUR HOUSE.
OR FOR THAT MATTER, FILLING YOUR
FRIDGE.
MANY COMMON GOODS, THE ONES YOU
BOUGHT AT A GROCERY STORE LAST
YEAR WITHOUT THINKING ABOUT, ARE
NOW EFFECTIVELY LUXURY ITEMS.
>> THE STATISTICS ARE
STAGGERING.
SHOWING FOOD PRICES ROSE 4.6%
THIS YEAR COMPARED TO LAST YEAR.
AND WHEN IT IS BROKEN DOWN TO
SPECIFIC FOOD ITEMS, THE NUMBERS
ARE EVEN HIGHER.
WITH DRAMATIC INCREASES IN MEAT,
POULTRY, FISH, AND EGGS,
RINGINGIN AT A MOST 10% MORE.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT IS GOING ON
HERE?
A LOT OF THINGS ARE GOING ON
HERE, AND THEY'RE HAPPENING ALL
AT ONCE.
THE MAIN DRIVER OF THIS IS THAT
OVER TIME WE HAVE BECOME
COMPLETELY, THROUGH VARIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS, BOTH PARTIES,
WE HAVE BECOME COMPLETELY
DEPENDENT ON CHINA.
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
EFFECTIVELY IS OUR NEW OPEC,
WITH THE WORD FROM A THEY CAN ST
DOWN OUR ECONOMY.
AT THE SAME TIME, THE IDEOLOGUES
IN THE WHITE HOUSE ARE RAISING
ENERGY COSTS JUST IN CASE YOU
THOUGHT MAYBE WE COULD MAKE UP
SOME OF THE GAP, DOMESTIC
MANUFACTURING, THAT IS
IMPOSSIBLE, WITH ENERGY COST
LIST HIGH.
YOU NEED CHEAP ENERGY IN ORDER
TO HAVE A MANUFACTURING ECONOMY,
PERIOD.
ASK ANYONE IN THE BUSINESS.
AND THEN TO ADD TO THIS, THERE
IS A LABOR SHORTAGE.
ONCE AGAIN, THE RESULT OF
LONG-TERM SAD TRENDS, BUT THAT
HAS BEEN DRAMATICALLY
EXACERBATED BY POLICIES FROM THE
BIDEN WHITE HOUSE, AND THAT
LABOR SHORTAGE IS HITTING,
PARADOXICALLY, AT EXACTLY THE
MOMENT THERE IS AN UNEMPLOYMENT
CRISIS.
THAT IS BIZARRE.
AND IT IS SCARY.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS ONE MEASURE.
THIS IS THE LABOR FORCE
PARTICIPATION RATE.
TONIGHT, IT IS 61.6%.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE 2008
MELTDOWN, WHEN WE FELT THE
FOUNDATION SHAKING AND PEOPLE
THOUGHT THE ENTIRE U.S. ECONOMY
WAS GOING TO CRATER, THE LABOR
FORCE PARTICIPATION RATE WAS
FIVE POINTS HIGHER THAN IT IS
TODAY.
THAT LOOKED CLOSER AT THE
NUMBERS, THE PRIME AGE MALE
LABOR FORCE PARTICIPATION RATE,
WHICH LET'S BE HONEST, IS THE
ESSENCE OF THIS WHOLE THING.
THAT MEASURE INCLUDES MEN AGE
25-54 AND WHAT WE USED TO
CALL THE PRIME OF THEIR LIVES.
CURRENTLY, THAT RATE IS ABOUT
88%.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
WELL, FOR PERSPECTIVE, TAKE YOU
BACK TO 1976, WHICH IF YOU WERE
ALIVE AND LIVING IN AMERICA
THEN, YOU REMEMBER AS A PRETTY
GRIM, TIME COME ECONOMICALLY.
INFLATION WAS WREAKING HAVOC ON
THE ECONOMY, WORRIED ABOUT
ENERGY PRICES AGAIN.
EVEN THEN, THE LABOR FORCE PER
DISSIPATION FOR WORKING MALES
WAS NOWHERE NEAR TODAY, 94%
APPEARED TO BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
THESE
NUMBERS, THEY HAVE NO PRECEDENT.
RIGHT NOW AT THE EXACT MOMENT
WHEN WE NEED HUNDREDS OF FACTORY
WORKERS, THOUSANDS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, YOU ARE SEEING SCENES
LIKE THIS.
FACTORY WORKERS WALKING OFF THE
JOB.
>> THIS IS CERTAINLY NO SMALL
SHOWING BY MEMBERS OF THE
LOCAL UNION, AS WELL AS OTHER
G.E. EMPLOYEES WHO SAY THEY ARE
NOT JUST FRUSTRATED BY THE
VACCINE MANDATE, THEY ALSO FEEL
BETRAYED BY THE COMPANY THEY SAY
DIDN'T GIVE THEM ENOUGH TIME TO
CHOOSE.
>> THESE FACTORY WORKERS HAVE
DONE A GREAT JOB.
I THINK THIS IS A SLAP IN THE
FACE TO THEM.
>> WE HAVE BEEN ESSENTIAL FOR 18
MONTHS, AND NOW, WE WENT FROM
HEROES TO ZEROS.
>> MORE THAN 200 SCHENECTADY
EMPLOYEES WALKED OUT ON THEIR
GENERAL ELECTRIC JOBS IN PROTEST
FRIDAY.
>> Tucker: SO TAKE THREE STEPS
BACK.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
WELL, THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
TARGETED A VERY SPECIFIC PORTION
OF THE POPULATION.
TARGETED THEM FOR IDEOLOGICAL
AND POLITICAL REASONS.
BLUE-COLLAR MEN.
THE IDEA IS THEY SUPPORTED THE
WRONG PARTY, THEY HAVE
RETROGRADE ATTITUDES, THEY
ENGAGE IN WRONG THINK, AND WE
ARE GOING TO CRUSH THEM.
SO SYSTEMATICALLY, THEY HAVE.
THE MANDATES ARE ONLY ONE WAY IN
WHICH THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAS DECIDED TO HURT THIS
SPECIFIC GROUP OF AMERICANS BEER
THE PROBLEM IS, THIS MIGHT NOT
BE EVIDENT TO THE GENIUSES WHO
WORK IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, YOU CAN'T RUN A
COUNTRY WITHOUT THESE PEOPLE.
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO KNOW HOW
TO DO THINGS.
NOT JUST REPORT TO THE HR
DEPARTMENT, BUT FIX THINGS,
BUILD THINGS, KEEP THE POWER
GRID GOING, FLY YOUR AIRPLANE,
ET CETERA, ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
AND IT IS EXACTLY THIS GROUP
THAT IS BEING GROUND TO DUST
BENEATH THE HEEL OF THE
IDEOLOGUES IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
SO WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR YOU?
WELL, IT IS GOING TO HAVE
MASSIVE A RAMIFICATIONS FOR YOUR
LIFE.
YOU CANNOT BUY BACK A
REFRIGERATOR IF THERE IS NO ONE
TO BUILD.
IF THERE ARE NO MATERIALS TO
ASSEMBLE IT, IF THERE IS NO WANT
TO PUT IT ON A TRUCK AND DRIVE
IT TO YOUR HOUSE.
SO IT IS A PROBLEM FOR CONSUMER
GOODS, BUT IT IS BIGGER THAN
CONSUMER GOODS.
AT SOME POINT SOON IN THIS
CONTINENTAL COUNTRY THAT RELIES
ON ITS VITAL TRANSPORTATION
GRID, YOU MAY HAVE TROUBLE
GETTING A FLIGHT.
SOUTHWEST AIRLINES, WE BROUGHT
YOU THE STORY REPEATEDLY, IS
CONTINUING TO SEE CANCELED
FLIGHTS.
WE JUST GOT THIS TEXT FROM
SOMEONE AT THE COMPANY.
"SOUTHWEST STILL CANCELING OR
SEVERELY DELAYING OVER A
THOUSAND FLIGHTS DAILY DUE TO
CREW NONCOMPLIANCE.
AS AN EXAMPLE, THIS PAST
SATURDAY, SAW 1352 CANCELLATIONS
DELAYED IN DALLAS ALONE, WE HAVE
OVER HALF THE BAGGAGE HANDLERS
NOT COMING INTO WORK."
AGAIN, THESE ARE THE PEOPLE
BEING TARGETED FOR PAIN BY THE
ADMINISTRATION.
AND BECAUSE NO ONE LIKES THIS
WORKS IN THE AMERICAN MEDIA,
THERE IS NOT ONE PERSON AT CNN
OR MSNBC WHO HAS ANY LINK TO
THIS PART OF THE CULTURE OR
THESE KIND OF PEOPLE, THIS STORY
IS ESSENTIALLY GOING UNREPORTED.
WHY ARE THINGS NOT WORKING?
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE WHO KNOW HOW
THEY WORK ARE BEING FIRED, OR
PUSHED TO THE POINT WHERE THEY
ARE WALKING OFF THE JOB.
SO HERE WE ARE AT THE END
OF OCTOBER.
THINK AHEAD A LITTLE BIT.
WHAT IS THIS GOING TO LOOK LIKE
IN, SAY, SIX WEEKS, WHEN THE
ENTIRE UNITED STATES DECIDES TO
GET ON AN AIRPLANE AND VISIT
THEIR RELATIVES FOR THE
HOLIDAYS?
WELL, WE'VE GOT TUESDAY'S
NUMBERS FROM THE WEBSITE FLIGHT
AWARENESS, SOUTHWEST IS ONE
EXAMPLE HAD 806 D3 DELAYS, THE
MOST OF ANY CARRIER.
THIS IS A PROBLEM AND A BOAT TO
GET WORST.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN ASKED
ABOUT THE TRANSPORTATION
STOPPAGES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WE PLAYED THE TAPE FOR YOU
BEFORE AND YOU'RE GOING TO PLAY
IT AGAIN BECAUSE IT TELLS YOU
EVERYTHING ABOUT THEIR
ATTITUDES.
HERE IS JOE BIDEN'S CHIEF LACK
BEING ASKED WHY CAN'T PEOPLE BUY
THINGS IN STORES ANYMORE?
HERE'S OUR RESPONSE.
>> PEOPLE COULDN'T GET
DISHWASHERS AND FURNITURE AND
TREADMILLS DELIVERED ON TIME,
NOT TO MENTION ALL SORTS OF
OTHER THINGS, SO WHY IS IT --
>> THE TRAGEDY OF THE TREADMILL
THAT IS DELAYED.
>> Tucker: YOU CAN SEE THE
LITTLE SMIRK.
THAT IS FRESHMAN YEAR DORM ROOM
AT OBERLIN.
YOUR TREADMILL DIDN'T COME.
YEAH, IT'S NOT JUST TREADMILL,
IT IS BREAD, DOG FOOD, KETCHUP,
BUILDING SUPPLIES, EVERYTHING
FROM A FLIGHT TO SEE MY AILING
GRANDMOTHER.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE NO TACTILE
SENSE OF WHAT THE COUNTRY IS
LIKE, SO INSTEAD OF ANSWERING
THESE MOST BASIC PROBLEMS WHEN
YOU ARE RUNNING A COUNTRY, YOU
CARE IF PEOPLE CAN TAKE FLIGHTS
ACROSS IT OR IF THEY CAN AFFORD
TO DRIVE THEIR OWN CARS OR BUY
KETCHUP.
INSTEAD OF ANSWERING ANY OF
THESE QUESTIONS, THEY ARE
LECTURING US ABOUT HOW WE SHOULD
BE DELIGHTED THAT WE HAVE A NEW
FOUR-STAR TRANS ADMIRAL.
THAT IS THE PRIZE THEY ARE
BRINGING TO US.
YOU VOTED FOR US, HERE IS HER
TRANS ADMIRAL, BE HAPPY.
AMONG OTHER THINGS, THESE ARE
TOTALLY UNSERIOUS PEOPLE.
THEY ARE PURELY IDEOLOGICAL.
THEY DO NOT CARE IF THE ACTUAL
COUNTRY, THE PHYSICAL COUNTRY
COMES A PART AT THE SEAMS, AS
LONG AS THE POPULATION DUTIFULLY
REPEATS THE CORRECT SLOGAN.
ONCE YOU UNDERSTAND THAT, YOU
UNDERSTAND WHY EVERY DAY WE GET
SOME FRIVOLOUS NEW ANNOUNCEMENT
ABOUT SOME SOCIAL JUSTICE GOAL
THAT IN THE END WILL NOT IMPROVE
THE LIFE OF A SINGLE AMERICAN
CITIZEN.
HERE IS TODAY'S EXAMPLE.
THE STATE OF DEPARTMENT JUST
ANNOUNCED IT WILL ISSUE THE
FIRST PASSPORT EVER WITH THE
NEXT GENDER MARKER.
HUH?
FIRST OF ALL WHO CARES AND
SECOND OF ALL WHY IS THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT TRYING TO PRETEND
GENDER IS NOT REAL, IT IS THE
REALIST THING IN HUMAN SOCIETY
AND THE BASIS OF CIVILIZATION.
BUT WHATEVER.
THEY LECTURED US TODAY, "THIS IS
FOR THOSE WHO DON'T IDENTIFY AS
MALE OR FEMALE."
SO YOU WILL NOT BE ABLE TO GET
ON A PLANE BECAUSE NO ONE IS
AWARE LOOKING AT THE AIRLINES
ANYMORE BUT AT LEAST YOU WILL
NOT GET MISSED GENDERED.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE, ONGOING HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE WITH THE HEADS
OF THE CIA, NSA, DNI, NOT ON HOW
THE INTEL AGENCIES HAVE BEEN
WEAPONIZED AGAINST AMERICAN
CITIZENS, NO, THAT WOULD BE TO
GERMANE, THAT MIGHT ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING FOR YOU IF THEY
STOPPED READING YOUR TEXTS, LET
YOU POST WHAT YOU WANTED ON
FACEBOOK.
THIS HEARING WAS ABOUT DE I.
THAT IS NOT A NEW INTEL AGENCY.
IT IS A NEW CULT, IT IS CALLED
DIVERSITY, EQUITY, AND
INCLUSION.
SO THE HEARING BEGAN WITH
ADAM SCHIFF COMPLAINING, AND
THIS IS A KEY PROBLEM FOR MOST
AMERICANS, THAT ALL THE INTEL
BRIEF OR IS WITH ARE WHITE MEN.
>> I CAN'T HELP BUT NOTICE THE
MAJORITY OF BRIEFERS TO APPEAR
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE ARE WHITE
AND MALE.
WE NEED TO RECRUIT OFFICERS WITH
DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS IN THE IC
AND SHOW THEM THERE IS A PATH
FORWARD TO ADVANCE TO GROW THEIR
CAREERS TO TOP LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS.
>> Tucker: OH, CAN'T HELP BUT
NOTICE MY INTEL BRIEFERS ARE
WHITE MEN.
IS THAT A PROBLEM FOR YOU
RECENTLY AS YOU ARE TRYING TO
FIX YOUR GARAGE?
A PROBLEM FOR YOU EVERY TIME YOU
FILL UP YOUR TRUCK FOR $3.30 A
GALLON?
IF ONLY WE HAD MORE DIVERSE
INTEL BRIEFERS, THIS WOULD BE A
BETTER COUNTRY.
THAT IS WHAT THEY THINK, THAT IS
WHAT THEY ARE SPENDING THEIR
TIME ON AND YOU ARE PAYING FOR
IT.
THE WHITE HOUSE JUST ISSUED ITS
FIRST EVER NATIONAL GENDER
EQUITY AND EQUALITY STRATEGY.
THAT HAPPEN ON FRIDAY.
DID YOU MISS IT?
WE HEAR YOU WERE WAITING IN LINE
TRYING TO BUY FOOD.
ONE OF THE HIGHLIGHTS FROM THAT
PLAN, THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS IT
WILL WORK TO END CASH BAIL.
OH, THAT WILL MAKE YOUR LIFE
BETTER.
BUT THAT'S NOT ALL!
THE WHITE HOUSE ALSO ANNOUNCED
AND WANTS TO COME AND WE ARE
QUOTING, "SEEK TO ELIMINATE
BARRIERS THAT PREVENT IMMIGRANTS
FROM
ACCESSING GOVERNMENT-FUNDED
SERVICES."
OH, THAT IS THE WHOLE GAME RIGHT
THERE.
SO YOU ARE GETTING POORER, GAS
PRICES ARE GOING UP, WE
COMPLETELY LOST CONTROL OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE COUNTRY,
WHAT ARE THE CHANCES WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE BLACKOUTS THIS
SUMMER WHEN PEOPLE DARE TO TURN
ON THE AIR CONDITIONING?
ABOUT 100%.
THE WHITE HOUSE, INSTEAD OF
SPENDING A SINGLE MOMENT TRYING
TO FIX ACTUAL PROBLEMS THAT
ACTUALLY AFFECT YOUR LIFE, HAS
TURNED THE ENTIRE FORCE OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON THIS
QUESTION: HOW CAN ILLEGAL ALIENS